over the past few weeks I've been Hunted
haunted
and mimicked millions of times across
the internet
it's been pure torture
thank you
two snaps for Wednesday
the Netflix
hit for season two it just felt
appropriate and let's just say Wednesday
Adams AKA Jenna Ortega has a kooky and
creepy reaction to the big news honestly
I wish I cared a little more
what do you hope to explore in a
possible second season I kind of want
her to be
to be done I want her to get more in the
nitty-gritty of things and not play
things so safe because there's a lot of
lines this one about her ah it's just
saving the school and doing whatever but
for me her main drive with the monster
was kind of a competitiveness kind of
man how's this guy doing this and why
can't I so I think I think I wanted to I
want to continue down an anti-hero
stream rather than typical hero now
Netflix didn't drop any details about
when the show goes back into production
or when we can expect to see that second
season screaming uh we mean streaming if
you hear me screaming bloody murder
there's a good chance I'm just enjoying
myself but it likely won't be out until
2024 at the earliest so until then it
wouldn't exactly be torture to re-watch
season one
get them out of here
now Wednesday is one of the streamers
biggest hits ever with billions yes with
a B billions of hours viewed in the
first month of the show's release
you guys are making me nauseous
not in a good way it's so popular
Wednesday's big dance number at the
school's Raven ball
okay
[Music]
I turned into a teenage
spawned endless Tick-Tock Recreations
including some from famous faces
so how much did Jenna have to rehearse
to nail Wednesday's viral choreography
well she got real on The Tonight Show
about how it all came together after
chatting with director Tim Burton he
came to my trailer about two days before
we shot it and said hey Jenna so I know
you said that you wanted to choreograph
the self because this yourself because I
refuse to see choreographer he was like
I know you got it you've been working on
it I'm not even worried about it I trust
you and I said oh yeah you know it's all
so good and I had not gone over it at
all you had no plan no
stream
[Music]
s